authorities Say gang members entered a
section of this woman's prison where
rival gang members were held
then inmates were shot and others were
burnt in the facility located in Tamara
north of honduras's capital
chances after at least 41 people were
killed they say they haven't been told
if their loved ones are among the dead
we are practically demanding that they
tell us what is going on as relatives we
are here with uncertainty will need a
list of the people that are alive
because we cannot get a list of the dead
until the forensic experts come and we
cannot get information from them but
while we are here dying of pain of
Anguish brothers and sisters we
definitely don't have any information
Human Rights Watch says there are an
estimated 40 000 members belonging to
MS-13 or Barrio 18 gangs in Honduras the
government launched a Crackdown in
November last year to try and eliminate
gangs which control and extort swathes
of territory
we're gonna
the deputy security minister says the
prison right is an attempt to stall the
government's progress
the Honduran people must know that we
will not allow under any circumstances
the attack or sabotage of the actions
directed against organized crime and the
organized criminality that is hijacked
the penitentiary system of this country
there's a history of prison violence in
Honduras 18 inmates died in a fight in
2019 and more than 350 others died in a
fire in 2012.
here at Tamara more than 20 children
also live in the prison
prison officers are trying to find out
if their mothers survived the violence
Barbara angopa Al Jazeera